remarque chenu d'artisans siro pied
depuis 2000 15 17 heures salle est ici à
chevreuse où il propose une soixantaine
de sirop pour halloween il va nous
apprendre en pharaon potiron et aux
épices
[Musique]
marc vous allez nous présenter un sirop
saveur un peu d'halloween est tout à
fait ça avec donc qu'on m'appelait
potiron aux épices mais c'est un c'est
de la peur note que j'ai travaillé dans
lequel je rajouter quelques épices là
par étapes ceux qui ont déjà des coupes
et 7 d'internet
une fois qu'elle sera découpée je vais
la mettre à bouillir pour ramollir un
peu la chaîne l'a mixé et ensuite je
fais le travail avec le sucre et les
épices
d'entrée le sirop montrez moi ça alors
là la botteur nate elle a été initiée on
va rajouter sur combien vous rajoutez
alors je sais à quelle autre pour un
litre de jus dont la limite 3 litres
d'eau plus la tornade donc il faut 3 kg
de sucre 1
[Musique]
pensez à ajouter du citron pour aider à
la conservation du sirop munissez-vous
ensuite un réfractomètre pour mesurer le
taux de sucre n'hésitez pas à multiplier
les tentatives en rajoutant du sucre
petit à petit pour atteindre les 55 %
ajoutez ensuite votre cannelle petites
astuces de marque chenu privilégiée mais
canal en b plus riches en arômes et plus
facile à travailler donc là ça y est la
plaque
donc je vais pouvoir intégrer alors pour
intégrer de la cannelle une épice dans
un sirop je vais y aller avec parcimonie
parce que si je mets tout d'un coup ça
risque d'être une dominante caennais
l'espace pour en faire ch
[Musique]
ça y est maintenant plus que la dernière
étape la pasteurisation pour la
conservation
on a notre sirop à winter wind donc avec
de la bonne note et la bête cannelle et
de la cannelle
alors à quoi il peut vous servir comme
on peut le déguster alors ça dont il
tait noir au lieu de mettre du tout
goûté ce sirop ça
sa feinte et gourmand on peut mettre ça
sur des fréquences en effet celle c'est
très agréable
et puis soul un peu plus d'originalité
mettez à face à l'avenir et ça aura un
petit côté châtaignes en plus
[Musique]